ever since we first learned that Luffy's
actual devil fruit is the mythical Zone
type honomi model naika there have been
theories about a secret category of
devil fruits devil fruits with Godly
powers that are stronger than all others
the real name of Luffy's devil fruit
sparked most of these theories because
naika is the name of an ancient sun god
back in skypia we were actually
introduced to four Gods who were
worshiped by the people of the sky
islands the sun god rain God Forest God
and Earth God and if Luffy has the sun
god devil fruit then could there be
other God fruits that correspond to the
other gods we know that greenbull has a
forest loia which is a strong candidate
for the forest God fruit and the rain
God fruit may end up being Monkey D
dragon's weather controlling devil fruit
but who has the final Earth God fruit to
find out click on my full video at the
bottom of your screen